okay t4 I usually go it's d4 against
this monster against this monster okay
last time this worked oh it doesn't play
the same lines it's gonna mix it up you
see c6 wasn't played before let's go
with this all right Queen d2 hmm there
goes that beep on huh yes yep yep yep
okay let's get some space I shouldn't
have done that pawn push I feel like I'm
in trouble that was a silly move I was
thinking I could just follow up with
this and meet Knight g4 with Bishop back
but my Knights getting ready to get be
kicked away ah and if I stop pawn push
with a3 then there's not here I'm losing
my dark square bishop but I'm gonna try
and make it work oh he didn't he once
again he did not do that he did not do
that did he nope all right what do you
got now what do you have up your sleeve
get out of there
that's the get out of my house move
expansion I'm coming at this computer
this pawn is pinned I better get out of
that I don't want a castle no way no way
I need more development in
pun man
I have my darks for a bishop where does
he belong well man there's gonna be
nasty stuff takes takes tonight here is
that working out or something I don't
think so
well soon find out it's not gonna miss
any tricks that's for sure
no tricks missed by this computer it's
definitely beatable it's definitely
beatable one or three minutes pawn push
just gives up this square kicked the
night away he goes here he's looking at
that well g5 Knight here and then King
f2 now this is gonna open up the
computers brutal brutal just gonna work
now here still in the agenda oh here we
go here we go this is the beginning of
the end I have a feeling oh yeah
I got a take here otherwise there's some
tricky stuff with there's just there's
gotta be tricky stuff okay can I get the
Queen's off it's my only hope maybe okay
how this nights gonna kill me
94 incoming what about c4 c4 let's try
got a try night here is still a bit
dangerous King here let's not set
yourself up for Forks there no way
Queen here if Queen here and this pawn
is dropping I just have to deal with
that Knight coming there I think this
nights gonna get to g3 who we didn't put
them play that there's some tricky stuff
with tactics here I think about Knight
up one minute thirty yeah that's what I
thought
Knight here
this is brutal 120 120 yeah pressure
pressure pressure pressure pound push
I'm dropping this man this is tough
clean here this is sad when you have to
start doing this go into defensive mode
big time that pawns hit this pawns hit
every pawn is hit pawn push takes takes
there's clean checks here that's gonna
be lights out how to defend like that
look at I'm babysitting all my pawns man
I should have quit after Game one man
yeah I can't I can't I can't defend
these things anymore that's not working
this isn't working really either oh I
may have I don't have any time either
crunched I can't get into these open
positions
I need closed positions against this
thing all right I resign